on episode 8 of Star Trek Picard titled
broken pieces we finally learned the
dark truth behind the synthetic attack
on Mars 14 years before the start of the
series and the crew of the la serena
makes some surprising discoveries here
are all the Easter eggs and references
you may have missed in broken pieces we
finally get confirmation and broken
pieces that common door Oh is what many
have long suspected a half Romulan half
Vulcan spy for the zot Vash who
orchestrated the attack on Mars where do
we begin on the world the humans call
Mars this isn't the first time Romulan
spies who are half Vulcan have played a
significant role on Star Trek in the
next generation series 4 episode data's
day data is assigned to serve as an
escort for a Vulcan ambassador named tip
L who later is revealed to be a Romulan
spy given that broken pieces reveals
that the zot washes mission to prevent
the evolution of synthetics goes back
hundreds of years it's safe to assume
that the zot Vash was weary of data from
the moment he was created perhaps Dipel
wasn't just a Romulan spy but was
actually an earlier generation of zot
Vash gathering information on
Starfleet's only sentient synthetic
after finding out in episode 7 of Star
Trek Picard that Agnes jarate had
ingested a Romulan tracking device we
learned and broken pieces that it was
made of Veridian despite never having
appeared in its shiny blue pill form
before iridium trackers have actually
been used in Star Trek since Star Trek 6
the undiscovered country in that film
Spock places a Viridian patch on the
uniform of Captain Kirk before Kirk
beams over to a Klingon ship later Spock
uses the Veridian patch to rescue Kirk
and McCoy from where they're being held
captive
Star Trek Picard has been doling out a
new ríos based hologram on the la serena
every couple episodes but by broken
pieces it seems as though we finally met
them all in total there are five each
with a different accent an emergency
medical hologram an emergency
navigational hologram an emergency
tactical hologram an emergency
hospitality hologram and one last
emergency hologram whom we meet in
Episode eight are you Chris
all I said I'm the imagine eating whole
time eyyyy while the different accents
and mannerisms of the various Holograms
are an effective way of differentiating
between six different characters that
all look exactly the same the cards
inclusion of a Scottish engineer who
liberally tosses around the word lassie
feels far from coincidental on the
original Star Trek series the chief
engineer was Montgomery Scott known
amongst the rest of the Enterprise crew
as Scotty while in the EE H appears to
be his own character and not a carbon
copy of Scotty his heavy accent and
Scottish slang all seem to be deliberate
tips of the hat to the much beloved
original character computer hello
computer when Rios acquired the la
serena he selected the self scan option
ostensibly by accident which led to the
ship creating five identical copies of
Rios however although the self scan
option seemingly preserved all of Rios's
memories the captain later went in and
deleted a few of them in order to cover
up what happened on his previous ship
the even Mudgett in the process Rios
also made several careless deletions of
unrelated information asked me the
proper temperature for making it Rhydian
T I no longer have any idea the eurid
Ian's were an alien species that first
appeared on the next generation when are
you ready a named J glum Shrek Lord Worf
to a Romulan prison camp by lying to him
about his father still being alive
the enh also says he's lost his
knowledge of Medicine astrogation
techniques the medicines are a
noncorporeal race first introduced in
the original series in the episode the
enterprise finds itself long into
uncharted space and has to use Medusa
aster Gatien techniques to get back
while Rios is sequestered in his
quarters we get a good look at his
bookshelves which is how we learned that
the captain is an avid reader of
existentialist novels and philosophical
texts including a Vulcan philosophy book
Zurich and existentialism the Vulcan
philosopher Zurich was first introduced
in the original series third season
episode the savage Curtain and is
credited as being the father of Vulcan
civilization of all the books on Rio
shelf
it's sur ex teachings that are the most
unique since he was a proponent of peace
his teachings led to the Vulcans purging
themselves of emotion while many of Rios
other books advocated for the value of
intense feeling interestingly it is Sir
ex teachings which are off the shelf
suggesting that it is the more
controlled Vulcan philosophy and not the
emotional earth oriented teaching which
Rios gravitates toward when he's feeling
lost when Agnes finally comes face to
face with a sentient synthetic in Shoji
she marvels over the many human-like
details in so jeez construction calling
her a wonder and a work of art
Agnes goes on to explain that while
Noonien Soong considered himself an
artist he never came close to creating
anything like Shoji this refers back to
the fourth season next generation
episode brothers in which soon likened
his creation of data to the sculptures
of Michelangelo saying his process of
creating data was similar but harder
wasn't quite that easy with you data but
the need to do it my need to do it was
no different than Michelangelo's knee
when Agnes finally comes clean about why
she killed Bruce Maddox earlier in the
season she explains that the admonition
was constructed to warn future
civilizations away from developing
synthetic life so that they could avoid
the catastrophe that befell its creators
once they passed a threshold of
advancement Rios immediately realizes
what Agnes is talking about likening it
to when Zefram Cochrane invented warp
drive in first contact it's explained
that Vulcans had thought of humans is
too primitive to make contact until they
saw Cochran's warp drive test flight
then they change their plans in order to
make contact it sounds as though there's
another advanced race out there that may
be ignoring the Federation for similar
reasons for now at least after gaining
access to knowledge that had previously
been inaccessible to her Shoji plans to
use a transwarp conduit to get back to
her homeworld which she hopes to reach
before the Romulans can get there
transwarp conduits were first mentioned
in the next generation episode descent
part one in which Geordi explained how
they were the ship when entering the
conduit is immediately accelerated to an
extremely high warp velocity it's like
falling into a fast-moving river and
being swept away by the current however
the technology played a much more
significant role in Star Trek Voyager in
which the crew made several attempts to
use transwarp conduits to make their way
back to the Alpha Quadrant although they
were unsuccessful the first couple of
times they
finally succeeded in the series finale
endgame when they used a transwarp
conduit to travel safely back to earth
on the bridge of the Lhasa Rena during a
quiet moment and broken pieces Picard
reminisce is that it reminds him of an
old memory I remember standing the Night
Watch is a young ensign on the bridge of
the reliance while we've heard many
tales of Picard service aboard the
stargazer throughout the next generation
he's never talked too much about his
time on the reliant however there was
another earlier version of the USS
reliant that played a much more
significant role in Star Trek history in
Star Trek the Wrath of Khan the 23rd
century reliant is commandeered by the
villainous Khan the reliant ultimately
wound up being destroyed in the final
showdown between Khan and the enterprise
but it appears that Starfleet later
commissioned another starship with the
same name toward the end of broken
pieces Picard mentions that he once met
Rios former captain when he served his
first officer to one of Picard Starfleet
Academy classmates Captain Marta Bhat
Anita's large about Anita's played a
central role in the next generation
episode tapestry in the episode Q brings
Picard back two pivotal moments in his
past allowing him to change actions that
he regrets MARTA botany tez was one of
those regrets she and Picard were close
friends but he never acted on his
romantic feelings for her initially he
decided to change this but ultimately
reverse that decision when he realized
that a romantic relationship would lead
to the end of their friendship Marta was
also present for the bar fight with the
nossek ins which ended with Picard
getting stabbed through the chest
leading to him receiving his artificial
heart check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you